can you tell us what happened on the
play where you got hurt and as you're
sitting there now
how does the pain compare to the other
times when you
hurt your other ankle this year i saw
the video you know
i don't know how to happen but it's not
no it's
not the bad uh honestly
i had luck he's my left hand it's not my
right
so it's a little spring and we'll see
more we'll know
more tomorrow over here
and rick said that you felt like you
could come back in and then you're kind
of not able to do the things that
you wanted to do once you're out there
um can you kind of take us through that
what made you think
you're good to go and then what made you
realize he had to kind of shut it down
i mean i just wanted to get him you know
uh i know we still had a chance to win
i helped my teammates but obviously you
know
i could run a little bit when i couldn't
push on my left leg
so you know it's better to to go out
and let somebody play
your ankle is not that bad how often
does it worry about
you know deployment was that how
optimistic
are you about being quite interested i
mean i don't know this isn't that you
know we'll see you tomorrow
uh we're gonna have an mri tomorrow and
we'll see
i think we'll know more tomorrow
rick said that you would kind of give
him a given him a nod
like this just isn't working out but
then when you sat
back down with like 902 left your guys
got back in it i think you were as close
as eight
did you want to come back in at that
point
i mean i want to go back in every time
you know but you know
you you always have a chance you know
you have great players
who often have a chance i know they
thought they come back eight
so i said to the channel as well one of
my team on the
okay tim mcmahon
luke obviously you were in some pain in
the fourth quarter when
you left if the score had been closer is
that a situation where you could have
tried to gut that out or was it
was it just were just not able to go on
at that point
just ask me the same question but i
don't think so you know
like i said you know i could run but i
couldn't push up my left leg
uh so it's better we have great players
so
it's better to be someone there you know
they can
they can go 100 percent